that's my plan oh um real quick who
would you think would win
Aragorn or Jamie they're both at the top
of their condition is just them both and
they're having a sword battle that's one
thing I hit on several these armor was
invented for a reason it's good to wear
armor if you're fighting with sharp
pieces of metal yes there yes their
disadvantages the armor you know if
you're if you're watering it full of
water you may ground particularly
chainmail which is actually heavier than
the plate most people think plateless
over here with none true really the
Milanese plate that by the time plague
came in at the end of last armor was
good people wore armor because it
protected them you know and you
consistently see in fantasy these
unarmored Saxons or thieves or something
like that growing up against fully over
advice and winning yes it did happen
you can be slightly faster and things
like that but the armor that has armor
on you did a sort doesn't cut through
the armor by and large just doesn't
that's why they don't look like maces
and battle axes of things they could
actually deal with plate armor most
sword glows glance off the armor or
leave a scratch on it but they can't get
through to steel so it Lauren character
would win over a gun without armor 99%
of the time certainly if they're both
skills fighters the unarmored guy has to
go for a row one of the few weak spots
like under the arm where you know you
don't have to solid armor you just have
some punches leather so pleasures are
covered in a light chain mail you know
if there's any gap in the armor if he's
only wearing a breastplate but his legs
or an armor a Bidoof little legs go for
the place where the armor isn't if you
have to in fact fighting in armor but
time after time again of these cage
matches Jamie is I thought Jamie
actually gets people who had no armor
and in those cases
now everyone never wears a full suit of
armor at all he wears I mean the Knights
of Gondor where are are as I recall in
an era where man does he have any
numbers yet male pacifically remember
you know
so my guys were armored so they in any
realistic match they would they would
read now of course the board air is
unrealistic because a lot of the fantasy
writers a person cheat and we were doing
I made a point to this is my realism you
know I got those from fans of ransom has
no matter lady with cheese you know well
sure if you say my plate is metrical it
because of anything you know Randall as
admissible armor that is it just stops
everything even though he's not
supposedly wearing anything so he has
all the advantages of being armored and
none of the disadvantages of being
armors no handy you know I come across
something that's when I did wild hurts
and I have an eye in that last magic
we're in low imprint was my knight from
Royal Guards to Congress of go steel
which is like superhero
just comes out of nowhere and he does
have a sort of effect do anything and
armor and even stop anything and so
forth
though even then we get a weak spot
because he has a price he has to see out
you know he has a I slit you know which
is a problem I don't like characters
have no weaknesses I mean is it too hard
lately but in the early days of wild
cards where had many different writers I
had one one writer who invented a
character who was protected by a
biological force field doesn't stop
anything so he couldn't be shot with a
ball as he couldn't have his arm hacked
over the sword or any any other thing
his force field was stopping and then I
had another writer who invented a
character who and bustle hands that can
cut through anything and the pristine
when these two characters tangled in six
I had to write at each of whom was
puffing up their cheeks and saying my
characters force field would stop your
characters before they happen no my
characters my ready has been through
anything contrary that force people you
know since the early things exist there
was no it son was rationally I just had
to
you know the Soudan cage matches were
like that you know where you know one
right over making an assumption that his
magical he would overcome and the fans
of the other character would break I
don't know my character has a magic will
stop the moon anything that would stop
it and it's over please the arbitrary
one more question here and we're out of
time
well it's it's it's not different but
it's it's more you know it's it grew in
grew in complexity in layers of
complexity and I like complexity I've
always liked the certain amount but it's
see it feels it feels real to me
we got
press release last week you may have
seen of that HBO had hired this guy to
create the Dothraki language pilot and
he went to this association of people
who make up languages for a hobby
language so they make up proposals and
they picked a guy David Peterson he's
invented to offer active language that's
all fine we release it in the press
release and I've been communicating with
Peter said the right thing and we've had
a mass communication a friend worked out
whether I can actually this over his
doctorate in the books which is sort of
a legally ambiguous situation because
it's owned by HBO by me but I see a
letter that came up on some vlog or
something other from some other guy who
makes up languages for a living
denouncing the the group that HBO
approached the language making up
association and as and you know on
whatever terms and I was just struck by
this because his long post about what's
wrong with it and you know there's the
guy who I think is a good guy has been
doing
everybody doesn't like this Association
and they have these attitudes they
doesn't like it just invited me likes it
for all the fights we have in the
science fiction writers of America and
you know how many people actually make
up fake artificial languages
I think Tokyo did it I didn't know there
was like a whole bunch of people out
there how many can there be who decided
to make up imaginary languages that no
one who ever speak except that when the
three people that they speak into you
know I mean most days languages are not
part of anything and yet for a smaller
group that was saying there are a
hundred people in the world who indulge
in this hobby they already have factions
and are fighting with each other over
policies of this and it just drove home
to me that this you know yeah you get
together the six people on your block
the former neighbor and Association and
there's gonna be the four people who
were together that do people made the
four people and who are gonna fight
about it so human life and politics
especially incredibly complex and I and
I try to reflect that so my life because
it's true and I picked up all the
fantasies and I don't see any of that
complexity it's the good guys
as the bad guys you know and where
where's the good girls would have 17
different factions they're all good but
they were learning in different ways and
Tolkien had some of that man those are
my favorite Tolkien characters are in
Boromir the grain character and Pokey's
have been guy but he's begun with floors
Emma for you know wonderful tragic turn
I find it much more interesting than
they did that the heroes and complete
villains I find
this interesting so so Plex Lee